how are you doing out there it has been
one hell of a year when it comes to
shooters kind of a rollercoaster ride of
emotions games coming out for free games
being broken new warzone maps coming out
so what we're gonna do in this video is
we're gonna take a look at everything
that just happened i swear to god in
just the past couple of weeks with three
of the biggest shooters coming out of of
the entire year and many of them falling
short and some of them surprising us so
i'm gonna jump in here with uh richie
bracamonte and phil hornshaw and we're
going to look back at the year in
shooters if you love shooters like we do
don't forget to give us the old thumbs
up and subscribe to the channel all
right let's get into it okay reggie so
let's talk about some ground rules for
each of these games we're going to talk
about how we got here how it's going now
and how we feel about this game moving
into the future so let's start with call
of duty all right just like last year
the way it's all the way it all started
was uh vanguard slowly inching in in the
warzone space and kind of just hinting
that it exists uh they dropped some guns
into the into into war zone some
overpowered ass guns and uh it kind of
got us hyped and they started finally
dropping some trailers and then they had
the big
war zone verdance ending that led us
into vanguard and the new pacific map so
um it wasn't anything surprising it was
all pretty familiar at this point but
not a bad way to launch a map
especially because it's not a new update
or a new a version of an old map it's a
new map so it came it launched to a
pretty good start with sufficient hype
uh that is if you're into world war ii
and vanguard because some people just
aren't and they're backing out this year
which happens every year but i feel like
with world war ii uh there a lot more
people just say nope um
so it was a little bumpy it was a little
bumpy for that reason but um
overall it was a good start um i think
and another thing another good start
that i really liked out the gate was how
they implemented vanguard royale
aaron and i have talked for
the last year about how the the gun meta
in warzone you know we all know it's
been busted at times they tried they put
all these band-aids on it and it's
slowly slowly getting repaired just
because of the amount of guns but what
vanguard did was uh they had they
introduced a special playlist with just
vanguard only guns so i thought that was
a good a good way to start it was the
only thing you could play in the first
day and it really got it it kind of
reset the meta for me it's the only mode
i currently play so i think we're off to
a pretty good start when it comes to
warzone okay so as far as how it's going
i think like i said we're off to a good
start we're still all honeymooning and
you know getting our prestige on
with the new guns and the the 20 new
maps that's something that's really cool
for vanguard specifically obviously the
multiplayer launched with 20 maps some
of them are remakes which is really nice
i think they're already getting silly
off the bat like this christmas event
that's coming up is
uh it's pretty goofy reminds me of
something treyarch would do but to be
fair um sledgehammer did the same thing
they always celebrated holidays and
goofy ways i feel like it's just
starting so early this year so we're
getting off kind of goofy with
skins and and and bundles and and things
like that so many you know people take
call of duty seriously especially after
the modern warfare reboot like i was all
in you know i was the same way i was
like get the clown bundles out of
modern warfare but it feels right here
it feels okay at least so it's a good
looking game overall there are still a
handful of technical problems a lot that
sledgehammer is trying to fix on the fly
which is good they have an ear open to
the community
uh there are still a few that have
seemingly been ignored especially in uh
war zone one i can think of specifically
is the spiky gun glitch is back
um that's probably the biggest problem
right now it's funny and it but
sometimes it it blocks it can block from
like 20 of your view to like
80. depending on what gun you pick up uh
just a little bit just a little bit i
think depending on how much how many
attachments you have
uh so other than that though uh warzone
has been
pretty fun um early on that's where we
are right now it's cool i think the hype
is
coming down a little bit but we're still
finding out things we're still
hopping in planes and breaking
boundaries and seeing what we can do uh
i'm excited a little excited for the
future only but i i hesitate when saying
that because
you know more guns will be added the
meta will
be corrupted once again at some point
but
right now where we are we're in a good
place uh early on but as far as vanguard
is a standalone game i think that's also
going pretty well uh it was a it was a
big launch again with 20 maps and i
think it's a fast-moving game i think
it'll be good for competitive league
this year um
there are some things that they've tried
that i don't think are sticking in my
personal opinion or like
the the kill cams they brought back the
kill cams which are fine but
when the game ends you can vote on you
know three players and their stats like
most multi kills uh you know uh fastest
time to kill all this stuff all these
these categories and you can vote and
uh for who played the best
and i think it just takes up time i'd
rather that just not be there i think
it's a quick way to sell like the little
emotes they do like they do a little
quick action move after they they
present who they are
it's okay i just kind of want the round
to end at that point
but you know can't blame him for trying
something because uh call of duty call
of duty goes through his you know it's a
cycle every year people
love it and hate it but
if they innovate too far then it's like
whoa whoa relax i'm not playing this
call of duty but if they don't do enough
then it's like
it's the same old call of duty and right
now i'm kind of somewhere in the middle
personally speaking um i'm having fun
but i would say it's a little less
addictive than
some other call of duty's from the past
um i don't find myself going back to it
like as frequently or i play a few
matches and i'm like okay i'm done for
the night i'm good
um
one last thing about the actual campaign
itself it was it was fun and flashy
and um i like the idea of they said it
the whole way through they're not
beholden to history but they're
you know they're they're using history
but they're not completely beholden to
it and i think that really i think they
meant that because there was a lot of
fun bombastic almost unreal things about
the campaign but it was fun you know i
had fun that was my bottom line and then
moving forward to next year what do you
think is going to happen with call of
duty
if the rumors are true aaron it's
looking good because modern warfare will
return for modern warfare 2. and no
matter what they do with that game the
hype will be very real for me because of
how much i loved modern warfare 2019
back in the day when
call of duty 4 modern warfare came out
and then the sequel came out modern
warfare 2 they innovated so much
even even to their detriment sometimes
because the game was broken in a lot of
ways but it became one of the funnest
most memorable call of duty games and i
was thinking to myself if if the modern
warfare reboot could have a sequel like
that that just blows the roof off of
anything we know that'd be so fun um i i
don't know if that's gonna happen but
but i'm hopeful for whatever modern
warfare 2 is
so i'm looking forward to that and for
the future of like warzone i would say
the only
you know fear i have is something i
mentioned before about
they're gonna
guns weapons they're gonna add more and
more throughout war zone throughout
vanguard
and uh we will have a crack meta once
again um that's the future i i see for
war zone but as far as the next game i'm
really looking forward to modern warfare
2
and whatever they do there so call of
duty vanguard might not have wound up
being the most exciting game this year
but oddly enough it was one of the more
stable games so now it's time to talk
about battlefield 2042 and how we got
here
battlefield 2042 was supposed to come
out originally before call of duty
vanguard which was really interesting um
they were announcing throughout the year
that they were like ahead of production
schedule
there was no campaign which was good and
bad but i think it really raised the
expectations that they would put a lot
more work into multiplayer
because where's all that campaign money
going it's got to be going into
multiplayer when the beta came out there
was this just that like classic dog on
fire in a room like this is fine this is
fine it's gonna be okay
kind of moment where like
it was just so clearly like broken and
the sky wouldn't i was playing on xbox
series x the sky wouldn't stop flashing
uh people were running around with their
parachutes out all the time
i didn't even realize how broken it was
until i started watching other people's
youtube videos and they were showing
people like going up and down stairs and
like 8-bit pixel art type animations and
it was it was bad it was pretty clear at
that point that the beta was too late to
make those corrections although they did
say that the beta was several months old
it was pretty clear they weren't gonna
fix everything before launch so i think
everybody had a big wake-up call
that those high expectations for
battlefield 2042 wouldn't be met
and then on top of that uh in the beta
people had very strong opinions about
specialists which we'll get into in a
minute okay
so how is it going
so far
it's wildly inconsistent i will say that
i've been playing a lot more recently
and i'm a huge battlefield fan played
battlefield for years and i actually
have had a really good time in the past
couple of days and a lot of it is
letting go of some of my expectations
like um playing very large maps i don't
try and get around the entire map
sometimes i will spend an entire match
just on one objective of the map um you
have those battlefield moments like you
can see the game wanting to get through
and sometimes i'll have a straight eight
or nine out of ten round but then i'll
have technical problems and i'll have
like a 6 out of 10 round or a 5 out of
10 round so like it's wildly
inconsistent but i can see the game that
wants to come out and i'm actually
having a pretty good time right now
that's not true for a lot of people out
there so a lot of people out there
looked at specialists and they just said
no this isn't for me like i don't like
the direction that they're going here um
it is too far away from the class system
and it you know i can't blame anybody
for feeling that way because the
specialists themselves have class icons
but they don't really fall within the
class classes at all or very much it's
one of those situations where
uh people had a big expectation for a
battlefield game and what they got was
this sort of call of duty inspired
specialist focus system now i will say
that i don't find the specialist to be
good enough or bad enough for me to have
a very strong opinion about them like to
me the specialists are just a piece of
kit they're like something i swap out
like like grenades or like guns um you
know i need to get over a wall so i use
mckay i need to heal my team or look
through walls so i go to pike um so to
me they're just a piece of kit but i
completely understand why people they
find them to be super cheesy and they're
just not good enough
the main problem is they're not good
enough to replace the old system and i
think that's the biggest problem here
here's the other thing you can see dice
made a series of cascading decisions um
you see this in rainbow six siege
sometimes so they'll make an operator
that breaks the game they'll make a
number another operator that fixes that
operator but then breaks something else
and then they make another operator to
fix that operator what you see here
going on here in battlefield is they've
they committed to 128 players they
committed to open loadouts that meant
that everybody got a rocket launcher
and that meant that vehicles vehicles
have to be able to take huge volleys of
rockets which means vehicles have to be
super tough
but the other side of that is that they
weakened rocket launchers so then
everybody was like now rocket launchers
are weak i don't i don't i'm not gonna
use a rocket launcher and now vehicles
are overpowered and like running over
everybody on the battlefield
and so
you know it's it's the series of
cascading decisions and you can see how
it happened you know we need to spread
the spaces out in the game
but
we didn't necessarily fill the spaces
with stuff you know like you have a set
piece and then you have a wide open
expanse of nothing and then you have
another set piece and what they needed
to do was fill
those areas with stuff so all of these
criticisms are totally valid
and
i can see why people are are not playing
the game but that kind of leads me to
how i feel about the future which is i
feel pretty optimistic about the future
of battlefield 2042 and here's why
one um portal
portal's a pretty fantastic mode and
portal allows them to put in old
experiences like 2142 past battlefield
games that people really want to play on
top of that the portal proves that they
built themselves like a really robust
fixable
system like the speed at which dice has
been able to fix problems is an
impressive accomplishment um
they can apparently tweak this game very
quickly on the back end in a way that
past battlefield games couldn't have
now does it have a lot of same problems
at past battlefield games that should
have been fixed by now yeah i mean i
think people were suspecting death
shield was back in the game uh where
somebody dies in front of you and and
you can't shoot through them but the
system that they built is pretty it's
pretty fixable that also means that
specialists might be able to eventually
get like crammed back into their their
class boxes which they probably should
be the other thing is and i'm i could i
could and be enthusiastic about this all
day but they finally put vince and
pellet in charge
and vince zampella he's the guy who made
titanfall in apex legends is really good
at tearing down genres
and figuring out what they are so if
you're like worried that vin sampel a
guy who made call of duty is gonna make
your battlefield game into call of duty
that's not what he's good at what he's
good at is saying how do we make a mech
game fun again and he made titanfall you
know like how do i how do i take a bunch
of titanfall fans and make a battle
royale game that's gonna like it
disappointed us at first but then we
were like no he was totally right and he
made apex legends so
i am so happy that i have been proven
wrong by vince impala more than once in
my life and
like
i was wrong about apex legends i was
wrong about titanfall uh initially
because i was playing battlefield and i
thought 6v6 was insane no way people
want to play that so
because of those factors because of how
easy the game is to fix apparently how
easy the game is to change how much
portal mode can add to the game and the
fact that they're now putting a guy in
charge who's really good at tearing down
genres and like figuring out what's good
about them
um and you know they said they're gonna
do an expanded battlefield universe so
i'm i am honestly hopeful the future and
i kind of hope people start drifting
back into battlefield 24 2 as it gets
fixed because i'm i'm having a pretty
good time i know i know
everybody out there is not happy with
battlefield
your your criticisms are valid
and
and you do what you feel what you feel
is right but i'm gonna probably hang out
in the game with some people who are
enjoying it for a while
um and i don't think my opinion is gonna
lead to
you know like ea
creating another huge hero shooter or
something like that you know there's
they're kind of talking about just
different battlefield games so don't
worry about it they don't listen to me
like
i'm enthusiastic about the future
battlefield despite all its problems so
biggest disappointment of the year for a
lot of people
now it's time to talk about the game
that
nobody expected
and i think it's time for phil to talk
about
halo
so halo infinite has kind of come out of
nowhere and
maybe taking the crown for shooters this
year despite some ridiculous problems to
be honest so
how we got here to start with we had
halo 5 which not super well received
kind of a weak campaign
really reliant on co-op with bad ai
partners who were just
so irritating like it was it was a real
problem uh multiplayer did it fared
better but you know it's been a long
time
uh in the interim we've had master chief
collection which had a rocky start has
been improving all along as more games
come into its on game pass
um it's really been cleaned up quite a
bit since launch you know had a lot of
problems when it first came out but
getting better so we've been you know
okay on halo for a while but it's been a
bit and we've been waiting for halo
infinite for like five years or
something we got that that pilot
uh video with master chief getting
rescued from space
like
what a million years ago at e3
and
so it's we've been waiting on halo for a
long time and also
let's not forget about craig right two
years ago we got a demo for the halo
infinity campaign that looked really
cool but also looked really bad like the
visuals were were real iffy it looked
like old gen tech uh we had a close-up
of a brute's face where he just looked
like a really smooth gorilla like a
really smooth
so you know and 343 took a lot of that
criticism and obviously worked on it um
we got later
videos of halo as we were coming up to
the release that uh i think
assuaged a lot of fears uh in that
regard and the game looks pretty good
now that it's out so it's it's been a
rocky road coming up here though right
and then all of a sudden uh
343 drops the halo infinite multiplayer
beta on us by surprise basically in
november kind of eats battlefield's
lunch which is unfortunate
but it was great it like we all got to
jump into this free to play campaign oh
that's another thing i forgot to mention
it's free to play now which
you know as we're hearing that
free to play has a lot of baggage
attached to it right and a lot of people
are like um i don't know
microtransactions
um but i think that that free to play
aspect of it has really been great for
halo it kind of makes the barrier of
entry really low
it's easy to hop in there's it's on both
pc and xbox series x it's on both game
pass and steam you can play it for free
off any platform that you want basically
you can stream it on your phone if
you've got game pass so
we got a lot of halo and all of a sudden
and it's really good it's a lot of fun
that's what we've been going through
up to now the last few weeks of halo
infinite have been pretty great um
multiplayer came out and was it's just a
ton of fun there are a lot of really
great changes that 343 has brought into
the game you can sprint now uh which i
think was a halo 5 thing but it feels
it feels interesting now because this
feels like a throwback to halo 1
in the way that it plays the multiplayer
with
the right improvements from the last few
years of or the last few entries of
343's games to kind of bring halo into
the future while still capturing what
made it cool in the past right the other
thing that we've got now uh we've got a
lot of new equipment abilities that are
similar to like the the armor abilities
that were back from reach
and that sort of thing we got the new
grapple shot which totally changes the
game super fun to use but there are also
a lot of other cool ideas like the drop
wall and uh the thruster and stuff and
used correctly really work to add a lot
to this sandbox
um that makes the game unpredictable and
fun and ridiculous in a lot of ways like
we've got a lot of people out there
doing mythbusters videos we did one of
our own and it's we just like screw
around in halo for a bit and see what
you can do like if you can reflect
rockets with the uh gravity hammer which
you can um but how that works and just
how ridiculous it is oh it turns out you
can reflect the skewer with the gravity
hammer too if you do it right
stuff like that has been a ton of fun so
there's a lot of chaos
in halo infinite that has made it
kind of the most fun multiplayer shooter
going right now
despite the fact that it is buggy as
hell and often barely works which is
really ridiculous i played three matches
last night with my friends and we
couldn't get a single one of them to
work correctly where all of us got to
play one kid was uh lost in the sky and
then he was lost under the map never got
to play didn't work never worked
one other match four of us just dropped
like in the middle of it we tried to re
uh rejoin couldn't left the fire team
left the match rejoined the fire team uh
you know separately wound up back in
that match still couldn't play it it was
ridiculous and so like
it's crazy out here that halo is as fun
as it is because it is really fun i was
addicted to it for last few weeks but
also it's still
uh it's a little janky so the halo
campaign comes out right and that is
also fascinatingly
uh up and down we've uh it's it's a
really fun
new take on halo it brings it into an
open world format
uh
brings a lot of open space and a lot of
ability to traverse around again you got
that grapple shot the entire time which
really really opens up halo as a game uh
i've always felt like halo was a lot of
fun as a shooter but i always i always
felt like master chief was kind of
moving through molasses you know the
loose gravity
is fun for a minute like in the campaign
but it opens you up to getting shot by
snipers basically all the time you can
never move your head it's always exactly
in the same place you know so now you
got this grapple shot you got the slide
mechanic you got the
sprint you got all these different
things that are bringing halo into
the modern realm of shooters and giving
you like more abilities to move around
with it feels really good the open world
stuff works really well for halo
generally
um giving you a lot of little different
experiences to have like capturing a
whole fort which is full of enemies has
multiple objectives or just like
dropping on a bunch of dudes who are
standing around in a fob and sniping
them when they don't know what's going
on capturing a banshee and just flying
around and shooting people who are on
patrol whatever it's good it works
really well again
it's a little
uh janky at times uh the open world
feels a little too big a little too
empty
um you know we've we've seen some
reports about the development of halo
infinite that kind of
play into the kind of way it plays it
feels like it was a game that struggled
a little bit in development it's been in
development for a long time and a lot of
things changed during that time
and yeah you can feel all that in the
game the story's a little you know
whatever halo 5 is still kind of
lingering in the background uh you know
and
so there's a lot that doesn't work about
it but there's a lot that really does
that redeems it and it makes it easy to
look over
some of those issues the progression
system for the battle pass has been a
really big sticking point that a lot of
people are having trouble with because
it takes forever to advance everything
is based on challenges right now and
then even as you are advancing and
getting experience and you're playing
multiplayer you're unlocking like one
shoulder pad at a time one little armor
thing on your little oh it's got bullets
on it this time cool all right like you
know
so
there are there are sticking points that
people have had but the current system
is good because 343 is obviously paying
a lot of attention they're making
changes to the progression system as
people are talking about it and it's
already changed significantly um the
multiplayer side especially is a little
thin right now there's not a lot of maps
not a lot of modes so it's expanding and
it's obvious that the developers are
paying attention and that they're still
working on the game and it's fun the
underlying core of it is really good the
sandbox is really good
there's a lot to really enjoy about it
so to segue into the future all that
makes me really optimistic i'm having a
lot of fun uh yeah sometimes it doesn't
work and we're like okay i guess this is
not the halo night but
sometimes it's a blast for hours and
hours and hours and the campaign is
super fun i just got through that like
two days ago and i've still got stuff on
the open world i'm gonna go clean up
which usually in a lot of these games
i'm like okay i'm done i don't care
anymore but i'm gonna go back i'm gonna
go finish it all out i'm gonna kill
every single stupid brute with every
single stupid gravity hammer i'm gonna
get all of them and uh
it's clear that 343 has a lot of work to
do but that they're also
committed to doing it and i think that
halo is only going to improve
as you know new modes new maps more
stuff comes into the multiplayer as it
finds its footing with the progression
system a little more it's gonna run i
think more of these cool
limited time events like the fractures
that we saw earlier in the preseason
where you get to the samurai armor which
is ridiculous and
don't wear it but also it was fun to
earn i had a good time fiesta was a cool
mode for halo
so yeah there's a lot to look forward to
it's still
there's still a lot of work i think that
needs to be done but i think it there's
only upward trajectory for halo there's
only oh there's only
further to go i think there's a larger
conversation on what beta means these
days like pre-alpha
beta we're gonna have to do a whole
other video on just what these terms
even mean anymore because they're
meaningless it's it's the game's
basically
it's basically out right
i mean it's out the campaign's out it's
doesn't this it was two weeks before the
launch isn't that launch isn't that just
the launch
this is just the game at this point like
i think you can
i think we're attacking beta on there
just to be like well sabrina please
don't yell at us too loud
which i get it you know that's it it's
like a soft launch
just real quick going around the room
and i think i already know what the
answer is but uh
richie what game do you think kind of
won this year in terms of shooters
oh man um i'm gonna have to say halo
like
i have
you know phil was just
uh phil just reminded me of how great
halo is and especially for a call of
duty player it's fast paced it's kind of
like
the the refreshes it took were like so
cool and like feels right like it kind
of just it put it puts it in more of a
modern place
and like we're thinking about halo again
we're talking about halo again it's
great i used to love halo but i felt
like some things sort of aged
anyway now with halo infinite i feel
like i'm you know taking all that back
and it's good it's heading in the right
direction so my answer halo phil i think
i know what you're going to say but
yeah i mean i've
i've uh really been enjoying halo it
really feels like being back in 2007
standing out front of the game stop with
a pizza we got from little caesars and
uh energy drinks and it's midnight we're
waiting for that launch like i'm having
a great time
um i will say that i really had a good
time with battlefield i really had a
good time with call of duty they're all
kind of like i think filling different
niches also but yeah there's just
something about the way halo works
with all that ridiculous chaos the fact
that some guns are hit scan and some
guns are projectiles and when you got a
projectile gun weird stuff's gonna
happen basically every single time you
know it's just uh
it's it's
cool there's a lot of really cool
underlying stuff that makes it hilarious
in halo and as much as i like those
other games and i did have a really good
time with them i don't know there's just
some unquantifiable nonsense in every
single halo match that makes it a little
bit more fun
and yeah sorry guys that's so true no
don't be sorry that's so true i've never
laughed in multiplayer so much in halo
it's still so funny like uh even from
halo one like just getting hit you're
the ragdoll like
uh that was the best they put that emote
in destiny it's been so good they did it
that's right though yeah
so but halo is just so hails multiplayer
just so fun and call of duty's is like
still fun and competitive and the
movement to movement is really good uh
but like it's so you know it can be so
sweaty
you're you're good in one game and
you're punished in a really high kd
lobby and it's like oh [ __ ] it's not fun
anymore i'm dying over and over uh
halo's a little more forgiving and
definitely more fun in multiplayer
man it does sound like everybody sort of
agrees that halo was the surprise winner
of this year
either way it's just been such a
fantastic
year you have so many options if you
love shooters right now so thank you so
much richie thank you so much phil we're
gonna go ahead and toss this one out to
the audience what was your favorite
shooter this year battlefield call of
duty halo or was it some game we just
didn't even think of here was it like
some crazy milsim that you really
enjoyed or how was it like a vr game
that you played
go ahead and hop in the comments below
and let us know we absolutely love
covering shooters and we're really
excited for whatever's gonna happen next
year
alright thank you so much everybody